[Música]
una de las peores catástrofes
ambientales y humanitarias que ha dejado
la guerra en Ucrania ocurrió en la
madrugada del 6 de junio cuando la presa
de Nova ka sobre el río nieper colapso
la cantidad de agua que se liberó inundó
decenas de comunidades río abajo mató
flora y fauna desenterró Minas
antipersona y dejó a miles de personas
sin suministro hídrico Sin comida y sin
luz
el Ministerio de ambiente ucraniano
Calcula que la presa La de mayor volumen
en todo el país perdió tres cuartas
partes de su capacidad es decir
alrededor de 13 kilómetros cúbicos de
los 18 que tenía originalmente semejante
cantidad de agua ha causado toda clase
de desastres provocó que alrededor de
42.000 personas quedarán en zonas que se
inundaron o que se podían inundar son
las que en el mapa están resaltadas en
Amarillo el gobierno ucraniano estima
que del lado oeste del río nieper y en
la región de gersón alrededor de 600
kilómetros cuadrados quedaron bajo el
agua y Rusia no ha publicado
estimaciones sobre lo que ha ocurrido en
las zonas que controla y que están al
este del río además el bajo nivel de
agua en la presa afectó el depósito que
suministra la refrigeración de la planta
nuclear de saporilla que está río arriba
y que es la central atómica más grande
de Europa
hasta ahora el cálculo del kremlin es
que el río volverá a sus niveles
normales A mediados de junio pero aún
quedan muchas incógnitas fue un ataque
deliberado de Rusia para retrasar la
contraofensiva en el sur un bombardeo de
Ucrania para dejar a la anexada
Península de crimea sin agua o una falla
estructural que afectó a territorios
ocupados por rusos y ucranianos y cuáles
son las consecuencias a largo plazo de
todo esto para conversar en el debate
nos acompañan desde Madrid Gonzalo de la
cámara director del Ice Center For Water
en adaptation de la universidad ie y
analista de asuntos ambientales y
también estamos con Enrique Ayala
analista de la fundación alternativas
experto en geopolítica y militar
retirado a ellos les doy la bienvenida Y
antes les quiero recordar a ustedes
nuestra audiencia que pueden dejar sus
comentarios y preguntas en las redes
sociales con el hashtag numeral el
debate f-24 en Twitter Facebook e
Instagram estamos como arroba franz24
raya al piso es y a mí me encuentran
como arroba maríacle Aguirre también los
invito a que escuchen nuestro programa
de las plataformas de Apple podcast
Spotify deezer y TuneIn
quiero comenzar entonces dándole la
bienvenida de nuevo a nuestros invitados
especialmente a Gonzalo de la cámara a
quien le quiero hacer la primera
pregunta Gonzalo Gracias por
acompañarnos Y hasta ahora Cuáles son
las consecuencias ambientales que se
conocen de lo que pasó en la presa
Hola cómo estás María Clara Muchísimas
gracias por la invitación Bueno en
esencia en la introducción ya señalabas
algunos de los elementos centrales 80
localidades a lo largo del río nipper
han quedado inundadas sin servicios
básicos con Gran riesgo de propagación
de enfermedades y contaminación hay que
pensar que a lo largo del río ingués que
es el uno de los afluentes principales
del nipper la catástrofe ha llegado 50
kilómetros más al norte es decir el agua
retrocedió si quieres en la dirección de
ese afluente y esto significa
básicamente que la cantidad de agua que
se ha desbordado con la destrucción de
la presa ha sido tan grande que ha
multiplicado en varios kilómetros la
amplitud del río hasta su desembocadura
esto significa que el caudal del río
básicamente ha llegado a triplicarse en
sus 60 kilómetros finales esto implica
lo que los que nos dedicamos a esto
llamamos alteraciones hidromorfológicas
se altera completamente las
características físicas del del propio
cauce del río y este perfecto que si no
es Irreversible no será fácilmente
reversible a un coste razonable las
pérdidas en realidad han sido más
materiales que en vidas pero todo ello
Gracias a que los municipios a lo largo
del río llevan desde 2022 vaciándose de
población porque el hiper como como ha
señalado marca un frente de guerra en la
orilla Oriental que da el ejército Ruso
y en la occidental el ucranio Pero hay
estimaciones por ejemplo del Ministerio
de política agraria y alimentación de
Ucrania que destaca que
del embalse ya podría derivarse la
desaparición del 90% de la red de riego
de la provincia de gersón o el 74% en
saporiya aguas arriba o el 30% en
micropetrovs es decir se están
produciendo impactos graves sobre
actividades económicas y en términos
ambientales lo que vemos
fundamentalmente es que el agua esa
escorrentía que se genera como resultado
del desembalse accidental en realidad es
un agua tóxica que
acumulando materiales químicos de zonas
industriales también fertilizantes de
zonas de cultivo fundamentalmente
nitratos y fosfatos también arrastra
residuos fecales procedentes de gersón y
al mismo tiempo también arrasado con los
cementerios que existía en esa zona para
que nos hagamos una idea el gobierno
ucranio asegurado que hay 150 toneladas
de aceite de motor que se han vertido ya
a las aguas y que hay otras 300
toneladas que aún están en riesgo de
filtrarse al nipper y una consecuencia
en este caso de carácter humanitario que
señalabas tiene que ver precisamente con
el acceso a Agua de la Península de
crimea
anexionada unilateralmente por Rusia en
2014 que en realidad
podría llegar a dejar de recibir agua a
través del Canal procedente del nipper
un saludo antes de profundizar un poco
en estas consecuencias quiero darle la
bienvenida también a Enrique Ayala
Enrique a usted Le quiero preguntar
la pregunta que todo se hacen y que por
ahora no tiene respuesta qué es lo que
se conoce de los señalamientos que ha
habido entre Rusia y Ucrania pues ambos
aseguran que el bando contrario fue el
encargado de explotar o dinamitar la
presa que se sabe que ocurrió y la
tercera opción de si fue una falla
estructural que tan posible es
Buenas tardes efectivamente todavía no
se conoce la autoría
cada parte hecha la culpa a la otra como
es normal En estos casos pero me parece
muy significativo que ni Estados Unidos
ni el Reino Unido han sido capaces hasta
ahora
de acusar a Rusia de haberlo hecho y son
dos países con unos servicios de
inteligencia muy potentes que están muy
involucrados en Ucrania y hasta ahora
sus portavoces y su gobierno de ambos
países Solo han dicho que están
estudiando la situación que están
estudiando las pruebas que están
analizando los informes de Ucrania y yo
creo que si hubiera la más mínima prueba
de que ha sido Rusia ya habría salido a
la luz
por intereses políticos y por tanto si
no ha salido a la luz
cabe dudar de que Rusia haya sido la
autora Aunque pueda salir en el futuro
pero por el momento la duda está ahí y
efectivamente Aunque la hipótesis
del accidente ha sido rechazada por la
mayoría de los analistas yo no
descartaría por completo porque al
parecer
circula por ahí una foto en la cual se
vería la presa unos días antes del
derrumbe seriamente dañada por los
combates y por el fuego artillería o
incluso puede haber sido una explosión
fortuita
en el interior de la central eléctrica
que tenía la presa o hay otra opción una
otra última opción y es que han sido
elementos irregulares de cualquiera de
los dos bandos porque el control exacto
de todas las fuerzas que se están
moviendo en el en la zona operaciones no
es completo
en este sentido usted menciona la
posibilidad de que haya habido una
explosión fortuita que hasta ahora no se
sabe primero si ocurrió Segundo si fue
Simplemente accidentada lo tercero si
alguien la produjo de manera intencional
al respecto norzar que es una matriz
sísmica de Noruega dijo que su estación
de Rumanía detectaron justo minutos
antes de que la presa colapsara que
detectaron en una estación en Rumanía
una actividad sísmica que correspondería
a una explosión en el campo de seguridad
qué tanta credibilidad puede tener esta
versión le pregunto a Enrique
pues en fin aquí lo que hay que analizar
un poco es A quién beneficia realmente
la destrucción de la de la presa y en
principio al principio todo el mundo
dijo bueno pues esto beneficia sobre
todo a Rusia porque va a impedir que en
esa zona se realice la ofensiva
ucraniana Y entonces
lo han inundado a propósito para impedir
la ofensiva bueno esto en fin yo creo
que hay que analizarlo con más con más
detalle en primer lugar por ahí no iba a
ser en ningún caso ofensivo ucraniana
porque el río antes de la inundación
tienen un kilómetro de ancho una
operación de paso de ríos es la
operación militar más difícil que existe
y sin superioridad aérea cruzar un río
que tiene un kilómetro de ancho es
prácticamente imposible puede haber
fin hostigamientos algunas acciones
anfibias pero por ahí no iba a pasar la
ofensiva ucraniana en ningún caso cuando
tienen mucho más al norte en zaporilla
como está pasando
territorio que es suyo y que está ya Al
otro lado del río y no hay que pasar
ningún río no Entonces sería un poco
estúpido el pretender hacerlo pasando un
río un río tan ancho y además Porque
si tú tienes el arma
de una presa que puedes abrir y arrasar
el terreno río abajo la utilizas cuando
están pasando
para
causar Las mayores bajas posibles no
antes de que pasen porque efectivamente
en un par de semanas el agua volverá su
cauce y Rusia se ha quedado sin alarma
que tenía si es que la iba a emplear que
no sé si la iba a emplear o no pero en
todo caso ya no la podría emplear cuando
pasaran yo creo que usted habla del agua
como un arma Le quiero preguntar sobre
este aspecto a Gonzalo Gonzalo Que tanto
se puede manejar un río como el río
nieper de lado y lado sabiendo que en
ambos costados del río vivían
poblaciones ucranianas y rusas
Sí bueno en esencia los recursos
naturales se han utilizado como como
arma de guerra en numerosos conflictos Y
esto no es algo que vayamos a ver en el
futuro es algo que hemos venido viendo
ya durante muchísimo tiempo si pensamos
en muchos conflictos geopolíticos que
están cursando en este momento con mayor
o menor violencia nos encontraremos con
que lo que ocurre entre Israel y los
territorios ocupados de Palestina o lo
que ocurre entre Egipto y Sudán del sur
lo que ocurre entre Etiopía y somalia o
entre India y Pakistán son muchos
conflictos que están vinculados al
acceso a los recursos humanos y donde
los recursos Perdón los recursos
naturales y donde los recursos naturales
se utilizan de facto como como un arma
de guerra existe la posibilidad por lo
tanto de que haya habido algún tipo de
planteamiento en este sentido ahora algo
que me parece importante y que señalaba
Enrique es más allá de hacer
afirmaciones taxativas respecto a la
autoría me parece Sensato esperar a que
avance Las investigaciones para conocer
más detalles sobre la autoría lo que sí
me parece importante es reconocer que
con independencia de quien haya sido el
autor o si ha tenido un carácter
estrictamente accidental Lo que sí es
importante es reconocer por un lado los
daños que los daños son altísimamente
desproporcionados y que en caso de que
exista una voluntariedad para generar
este daño estamos ante eso que se ha
dado en llamar ecocidio y aquí es
importante señalar que el ecocidio en
sentido estricto no está reconocido como
crimen internacional lo que está
reconocido como crimen internacional es
el uso de este tipo de infraestructuras
Kim críticas como arma de guerra porque
eso está ya específicamente recogido en
la convención de Ginebra que lo señala
como crimen de guerra pero lo que lo
convierte en crimen de guerra no es su
categoría de ecocidio sino el hecho de
que se atente contra una infraestructura
crítica y precisamente usted menciona
una palabra clave en todo este debate y
es ecocidio porque Ucrania ha defendido
y ha reiterado que los rusos serían
culpables de una ecocidio y como usted
bien lo señala no vamos a profundizar en
quien pudo haber sido el autor porque es
algo que todavía no se conoce pero sí en
las posibles consecuencias dentro de
ello Gonzalo Le quiero preguntar qué
determina que sea un ecocidio Y si esta
palabra se puede aplicar o no en este
momento
sí es es una discusión muy interesante
que se ha planteado en relación a la
reforma del estatuto de Roma que en el
año 98
se aprobó para constituir La Corte Penal
Internacional como quizás sepa muchas de
las personas que nos escuchan en este
momento la Corte Penal Internacional
sólo puede perseguir cuatro tipos de
crímenes el genocidio los crímenes de
lesa humanidad los crímenes de guerra y
lo que ya lo que llamamos ahora crímenes
de agresión Pero hay una corriente
importante en los últimos años para
Añadir un quinto tipo de delito que
serían estos ecocidios el ecocidio se
define como un acto ilegal y
clarísimamente
deliberado cometido con conocimiento de
que hay una probabilidad nítida de que
esos actos en este caso lo que podría
suponer un atentado contra una
infraestructura tan importante como esta
causen daños graves y generalizados y a
largo plazo en el medio ambiente por lo
tanto hay cinco elementos que nos
permitirían hablar de ecocidio el
primero es que sea un daño deliberado es
que haya un desprecio Si se quiere
Temerario en relación a daños que son
claramente desproporcionados en relación
a los beneficios sociales y económicos
que podrían proporcionar por otro lado
que sea Severo es decir que los cambios
adversos sean muy serios como ocurre en
este caso por otro lado que sea de
carácter generalizado es decir que no
sea puntual que no sea local sino que se
extienda en un área geográfica
esencialmente amplia por otro lado que
sea a largo plazo es decir que tenga
cierto carácter Irreversible o por lo
menos en un periodo de tiempo razonable
y a un coste razonable Y por último que
esté afectando nítidamente a eso que
llamamos en llamar en medio ambiente en
este caso hay una afección nítida a
recursos de agua al suelo y por supuesto
como señalabas en tu Introducción a
recursos de flora y fauna y una un daño
clarísimo a determinados ecosistemas y
por lo tanto entraría dentro de eso que
se dan llamar ecocidio
Enrique usted coincide con esta postura
de que se podría hablar de ecocidio y
además qué tanto se ha utilizado los
recursos naturales dentro de Las Guerras
concretamente dentro de la de Ucrania
bueno es curioso pero en el año 1941
cuando el ejército del Tercer Reich el
ejército nazi invadió Rusia
está linizo volar una presa en el río
nipper y causó decenas de miles de
Muertos porque él sí la hizo estallar
cuando estaba o la hizo desbordar cuando
estaba cruzando el río no no antes no se
ha empleado muchas veces y
se emplea como como arma
continuamente en distintos conflictos lo
que pasa es que hay que puntualizar que
Rusia no forma parte de la Corte Penal
Internacional
ni tampoco Estados Unidos ni tampoco
Ucrania y por tanto
cuando se habla de acusar a las
autoridades rusas
de haber hecho un ecocidio de haber
hecho un
un ataque una infraestructura civil que
efectivamente está recogido como ilegal
en los convenios de Ginebra pues tendría
que ser una Corte Penal especial que se
creara para para estos asuntos porque la
Corte Penal Internacional en este caso
diríamos no tendría la capacidad de
actuar a no ser que en las autoridades
rusas salieran de Rusia y entrar en un
país que sí hubiera suscrito
fuera parte
de la Corte Penal Internacional y de ahí
si podrían ser detenidas Enrique Le
quiero preguntar sobre qué tan
estratégico sería desde la parte militar
del lado de los rusos siquiera
plantearse la opción de destruir esta
presa porque tengamos en cuenta que el
río nieper surte de agua dulce también a
la Península anexada de crimea a través
del canal
de crimea del Norte teniendo esto en
cuenta que tan estratégico Sería para el
kremlin plantearse la posibilidad de
hacer un daño Y si esta versión para
usted tiene sentido o no
bueno Por una parte efectivamente
el agua que recibe crimea procede el río
nipper precisamente una de las razones
probables de la invasión fue que Ucrania
estaba
restringiendo
de una manera grave el agua que llegaba
crimea cuando esta zona estaba en su
poder
naturalmente la interrumpe la presa
afecta a este suministro de agua pero en
fin yo creo que pueden recibir agua del
río directamente O sea que no creo Puede
que haya una disminución del caudal pero
no creo que mientras el canal esté en
poder de los rusos
crimea pierda todo suministro de agua
por otra parte Aunque desde el punto de
vista
ecológico y agrícola la parte
ucraniana ha sido muy muy afectada sobre
todo en el tema de los regadíos en el
tema
de la inundación incluso de gerson pero
desde el punto de vista militar se ha
perjudicado más al lado ruso porque ha
arrasado los campos de minas las
defensas obstáculos que tenían en esa
zona e incluso las minas que había en el
río que ahora pues en fin se han sido
arrastradas de verdad y construyeron un
peligro importante porque pueden
con el río desbordado llegar a cualquier
sitio en ambas orillas y hacer explosión
por tanto
ninguno de los dos me sale favorecido
con esta acción y entonces es difícil
verdad encontrar qué motivación han
podido tener cualquiera de ellos por eso
digo que la hipótesis de que haya sido
algún tipo de fuerza no controlada
exactamente por los respectivos
gobiernos
incluso la del accidente o que menos
probable parece que podría que podría
tener alguna alguna verosi militud
Enrique mencionaba precisamente la
afectación de los sistemas de riego que
ya Gonzalo había hablado Gonzalo yo le
quiero preguntar en términos
hídricos Cómo se pueden recuperar esos
sistemas de riego sobre todo hablando a
mediano y corto plazo
bueno en sentido estricto aquí
tendríamos que distinguir entre lo que
son los efectos inmediatos a corto plazo
Lo que implica una emergencia
humanitaria de una manera más clara y lo
que implica ya una destrucción de
potencial productivo a largo plazo si se
trata de reconstruir infraestructuras
estamos hablando de que nada Puede
ocurrir en el corto plazo Tendremos que
esperar a que haya una reconstrucción no
solo De esta zona sino probablemente del
país al final del conflicto bélico para
ver cómo se recuperan este tipo de
sistemas productivos si estamos hablando
de una afección a corto plazo entonces
lo que vamos a ver es que incluso aunque
se recuperase en las condiciones del Río
en un plazo relativamente breve ese daño
en las infraestructuras probablemente
implicaría la pérdida de determinadas
cosechas Más allá del elemento que
señalaba antes de el carácter tóxico de
estas correntía que se genera como
resultado de una crecida artificial Si
se quiere de Agua que va arrastrando
campos de cultivo zonas industriales
residuos procedentes de aguas residuales
vinculados a nuestros hogares es decir
este tipo de siempre se dice cuando
hablamos de desastres naturales que por
ejemplo un huracán una tormenta tropical
no mata por el viento mata por el agua
pero en este caso en realidad si
pensamos en pérdidas humanas no ha sido
tan evidente porque es muy difícil hacer
estimaciones pero hay que pensar que más
más o menos la mitad de los casi 300.000
habitantes que vivían en gersón antes
del inicio del conflicto continúan en la
ciudad pero la otra mitad marchó
Entonces es muy difícil saber
exactamente De cuántos desplazados
forzosos estamos hablando en este
momento lo que sabemos que ha habido en
los últimos días un Éxodo de
aproximadamente varias decenas de miles
de personas muchas de ellas abandonando
la ciudad en
o las zonas afectadas en sus vehículos
privados pero es difícil saber de qué
estamos hablando Lo cierto es que la
afección tanto sobre el regadío como los
sistemas de provisión de agua potable y
saneamiento como la recuperación de este
tipo de actividades productivas no es
algo que vaya a ocurrir en el corto
plazo en absoluto digamos que esto es un
desastre que se suma al desastre
preexistente
profundicemos en las sustancias tóxicas
que usted menciona porque al respecto
una ong independiente que es el grupo de
trabajo de consecuencias ambientales de
la guerra en Ucrania dice que hay
toxinas que se están quedando en el lodo
y que cuando llegue el verano esto se
podría convertir en un polvo venenoso A
qué corresponderían estas toxinas a toda
la mezcla de fertilizantes desde las 150
toneladas de aceite o a qué
concretamente
en realidad es lo que se producen son
una serie de reacciones químicas
precisamente como resultado del
descontrol en estos normalmente esos
contaminantes en un sistema organizado
en cualquier economía avanzada del
planeta son capaces de tratarse de
manera independiente los llevamos a una
depuradora una estación de tratamiento
de aguas servidas de aguas residuales y
allí reciben un tratamiento específico
cuando eso se combina en el medio de una
manera entrópica de una manera
desordenada entonces lo que vemos es que
se pueden producir una serie de
reacciones químicas que podrían llevar a
ese tipo de impactos sobre sobre la
salud humana es muy importante pensar
que en realidad Incluso si algunos de
estos contaminantes no afectasen de
manera directa a la salud humana en la
práctica por ejemplo pueden contribuir a
la contaminación de suelos y de
acuíferos que en realidad son esenciales
para el mantenimiento de determinadas
actividades productivas y humanas es
esto es básicamente lo que estamos
viendo en este momento hay que pensar
que ese agua arrastra todo y arrastra de
manera descontrolada y por lo tanto es
muy difícil saber en qué momento y en
qué lugar concreto nos estamos
enfrentando a una amenaza específica
Esta es la la dificultad básica con la
que se encuentra uno cuando cuando ve
una situación catastrófica de estas
características y por eso lo más
probable es que las consecuencias las
veamos
en un
himno inmediata como lo vemos con las
inundaciones Enrique Yo le quiero
preguntar sobre una de esas posibles
consecuencias a largo plazo usted
mencionó previamente las minas
antipersona una vez el agua se seque se
drene es posible que estas Minas sigan
activadas
bueno no son Minas antipersonas son
Generalmente Minas antitanque también
hay minas antipersona esas Minas están
ahora fuera de control hay algunas que
han hecho explosión otras han sido
arrastradas por el agua y pueden ir a
cualquier sitio dentro de las en el
marco en el ámbito de las inundaciones y
por tanto pueden afectar lógicamente a
la población civil Así que eso es un
peligro que está ahí Todavía no se ha
terminado de resolver Y tardará en
resolverse porque puede haber quedado
cuando bajen las aguas Pues en cualquier
sitio y cuando se empiecen los trabajos
de desescombro y de reacondicionamiento
del terreno y tal pues puede suceder que
se encuentran esas Minas y algunas de
ellas podrían hacer explosión por tanto
esa es un peligro efectivamente añadido
que ha quedado como consecuencia de la
rotura de la presa
Pero además todo este
reacondicionamiento como usted lo llama
ocurrirá todavía en medio de la guerra
todo lo que está pasando con esta presa
Cómo puede impactar a la contraofensiva
ucraniana Enrique
Bueno yo creo que
la reconstrucción se hará cuando termina
la guerra me imagino No es difícil que
bajo el fuego artillería se puedan poner
a trabajar para volver a recuperar ni en
un lado ni en otro los
las infraestructuras que tenían
anteriormente yo creo como he dicho
antes yo creo que esto no va a afectar
mucho a la ofensiva de hecho la ofensiva
ha comenzado ya estamos en los inicios y
ha empezado por el sitio más Lógico es
decir entre saporilla y Daniels es una
zona donde las tropas ucranianas ya
estaban en la margen izquierda del río
es decir en la margen occidental
Oriental del río y por tanto no tenía
que pasar ningún río entonces en fin es
que era un poco
[Música]
extravagante de pensar que iban a hacer
la ofensiva como dije antes de un río de
un kilómetro de ancho produciendo al
hacer directamente por por Tierra Firme
no así que la ofensiva
se está empezando a producir todavía
estamos en las primeras fases y se está
empezando a producir por donde estaba
previsto Es decir
para partir en dos en la zona ocupada
por Rusia y aislar
crimea
del resto del territorio ruso u ocupado
y probablemente haya algún otro esfuerzo
más al norte Y quizá como he dicho antes
también Algún puede haber algún esfuerzo
anfibio en el sur en la zona de incluso
la desembocadura del hiper pero no un
esfuerzo principal Por tanto la
contrapresión no se ve afectada
realmente por por esta por esta
inundación En mi opinión si bien Estamos
hablando de lo que ocurrió en la pres a
de novakahovka esto en las regiones de
saporilla gerson y Pro hay otra noticia
sobre otra presa ubicada en el río macri
yali en la región de doniesk Y es que
las autoridades de tabría afirman que
los rusos habrían volado otra
hidroeléctrica allí o abrían por un lado
una hidroeléctrica allí el pasado
domingo Gonzalo se sabe de las
consecuencias de esto sobre todo las
consecuencias ambientales
Bueno todavía no no hay mucha
información en este caso todavía hay
incluso más incógnitas que en el caso
donde la presa a la que nos hemos estado
refiriendo pero en realidad si
analizamos como decía antes Enrique no
estamos hablando de la primera
infraestructura crítica que se destruye
en un conflicto bélico si analizamos las
consecuencias normalmente suelen ser
siempre muy parecidas estamos hablando
de una crecida artificial es decir en el
cauce de un río se produce por un lado
una afección clarísima de la cantidad de
agua disponible aguas arriba y aguas
abajo porque antes mencionaba Enrique
saporilla y en saporiya el problema que
se plantea no es solo en relación a la
refrigeración de su central nuclear que
nos aseguran que no va a ser afectada
por lo que ha ocurrido en esta presa
pero sí que se produce una afección a
medio millón de hectáreas cultivables en
torno al 2% del suelo agrícola del país
que van a ver como de repente tienen un
problema de escasez de agua más que
notable y esto en contexto en el que hay
que recordar que si miramos a lo que
ocurrió exactamente hace un año en el
verano europeo el agua se puso en el
centro del escenario también Incluso en
términos geopolíticos porque de repente
algunos ríos importantísimos del centro
y el este de Europa como el danubio el
Elba o el ring se vieron afectados por
una sequía muy intensa que llevó a la
afección de determinadas a la disrupción
de determinadas cadenas de suministro
críticas por ejemplo de semiconductores
o de fertilizantes en el contexto de una
crisis de seguridad alimentaria a nivel
mundial o de gas natural en el contexto
de la peor crisis energética en los
últimos 50 años es decir este tipo de
cuestiones tienen una afección que
estrictamente local que tiene que ver
con la emergencia humanitaria pero
estamos empezando a ver como todo lo que
ocurre en relación a la gestión del
capital natural ocupa el centro del
escenario también en términos
geopolíticos y dirige nuestra atención
hacia estos temas que tradicionalmente
formaban parte de la periferia nuestros
análisis en términos geopolíticos y
teniendo en cuenta Esta conexión de la
que usted nos habla de los recursos
naturales con la geopolítica
en medio
de la guerra esperar más ataques en
torno a la naturaleza que puedan afectar
al enemigo
Bueno yo estoy Completamente de acuerdo
con con Gonzalo
el agua a medida que avanza el cambio
climático el calentamiento global se
está convirtiendo en un recurso cada vez
más escaso Y a medida que es un recurso
que además escaso pues es más fuente de
conflictos y será en el futuro una de
las fuentes de conflictos más
importantes posible que todas las
guerras que hemos visto en el pasado
alrededor del petróleo puede haberlos en
el futuro alrededor del agua yo creo que
esto es es importante y que marca un
punto de
inflexión en Las Guerras por lo menos en
las que ha habido hasta ahora en suelo
europeo la utilización del agua y sobre
todo la destrucción de una presa tan
grande como esta la mayor de Europa con
que nos está explicando Gonzalo
naturalmente es un hito verdad en la en
la guerra moderna sobre todo ya digo
entre países que supone que son
civilizados y no me extrañaría nada que
en el futuro pues aparte de esta presa
que has citado que es menor podemos ver
algún tipo de utilización de otras
infraestructuras de carácter civil ya
hemos visto la destrucción de algunas
con objeto de tener ventaja en el
conflicto Gonzalo cree usted también que
puede haber un punto de inflexión desde
lo que ocurrió en la presa de Nova
kahofka
sí sin duda es decir pero yo creo que
hay un punto de inflexión si vamos hacia
atrás en el propio conflicto y un punto
de inflexión en el sentido de que lo que
está ocurriendo en Ucrania está
ocurriendo apenas cinco horas en avión
de las ciudades de la que hablamos
Enrique y yo está ocurriendo como una
ilustración de la dialéctica que se
plantea entre la democracia
representativa como modo de coexistencia
y el nacional populismo la autocracia es
decir hay muchas cosas que están
ocurriendo que quizá habíamos menos
valorado que pensábamos que no podían
ocurrir sorprendentemente porque en el
2014 se produjo una ocupación de la
Península de crimea que me corregirá
Enrique pero en los últimos años ha
generado no sé si 14.000 o 15.000
víctimas en ese conflicto que ha
permanecido de alguna manera como
latente como larvado para la mayor parte
de la opinión pública Europea y por
señalar un elemento adicional en
relación a lo que mencionaba antes
respecto al verano pasado y a esa
confluencia de una crisis climática una
crisis de agua una crisis de seguridad
alimentaria y una energética el año
pasado precisamente como resultado el
conflicto en Ucrania hubo un intento por
parte de economías occidentales europeas
entre ellas la primera economía de la
Unión Europea Alemania para reducir sus
niveles de dependencia de las
importaciones de gas natural Ruso y esto
En parte implicó la necesidad de aprobar
un proyecto entre la República Federal
de Alemania y España que cruzaba por
Francia ese ese proyecto fue un proyecto
que encontró la oposición de un
europeísta conocido el presidente macron
y ese proyecto cuando macron se oponía
en parte se oponía porque Francia tiene
resuelta la generación de energía
eléctrica en un 70% a partir de
reactores nucleares Bueno pues 32 de los
56 reactores nucleares en Francia el año
pasado en verano estaban detenidos como
resultado un problema de mantenimiento
un problema de corrosión y el resto
tuvieron que hacer esfuerzos improbos
para mantener los niveles de generación
de energía eléctrica con problemas de
suministro de agua y de suministro de
como en una temperatura correcta para
hacer la refrigeración de esos reactores
nucleares es decir los temas ya no son
estrictamente sectoriales ya no son solo
energéticos solo de agua o solo de
agricultura y alimentación los temas son
complejos Y tenemos yo creo que parte
del imperativo es gestionar la
complejidad claro y confluyen sin duda
alguna para terminar nuestro programa
Enrique muy brevemente
inclusión de cómo entender este daño y
este colapso de la presa novaka
Bueno yo creo que hay que esperar a que
se realice una investigación
exhaustiva que se conozcan efectivamente
quienes han sido los autores Y entonces
podremos
establecer ya un poco Cuáles son las
razones que han movido a esta explosión
por el momento esto no afecta al curso
de la guerra ha afectado mucho a la
población por supuesto y a la terreno
que ha sido inundado pero la ofensiva de
Ucrania continúa y vamos a ver qué pasa
Porque del resultado es ofensiva
seguramente va a depender el que pueda
establecerse una negociación y pueda dar
fin a la guerra tanto si tiene éxito
como si fracasa Gonzalo y su conclusión
Sí mi conclusión fundamental es que
tenemos que ser capaces de entender que
en este momento como señalaba antes
vivimos con unos niveles de
incertidumbre y de complejidad
probablemente sin precedentes y es
importante atender a este tipo de
cuestiones como la que nos convoca hoy
en este debate no solo desde una
perspectiva estrictamente local no solo
es una perspectiva anecdótica sino
entendiendo cada uno de este tipo de
eventos catastróficos como una
ilustración de problemas de mayor escala
a los que nos estamos viendo enfrentados
los ciudadanos en este momento europeos
pero los ciudadanos del mundo en su
conjunto Gonzalo de la cámara y Enrique
Ayala Gracias por acompañarnos aquí en
France 24 y a ustedes nuestra audiencia
Gracias por estar aquí en France 24
sigan con nosotros
[Música]